IT'S MEANT TO REDUCE HOSTILITIES
ON THE PENINSULA.
OBVIOUSLY WE'LL FOLLOW THIS ALL
NIGHT.
IN RECENT YEARS, THE DIGITAL
VIDEO MONOPOLY YOUTUBE WHICH IS
PART OF THE DIGITAL SEARCH
MONOPOLY GOOGLE HAS BEEN ACCUSED
OF TRYING TO SILENCE
CONSERVATIVE VIEWPOINTS.
CONTENT PROVIDERS HAVE FOUND
THEMSELVES CENSORED.
YOUTUBE DENIES DOING ANY OF THIS
ON PURPOSE.
IT WAS ACCIDENTAL.
THEY SAY WE HAVE NO POLITICAL
AGENDA.
IT TURNS OUT THAT'S A LIE.
THIS SHOW HAS EXCLUSIVELY
OBTAINED A YOUTUBE MEMO FROM
APRIL 2017 THAT LAYS OUT IN
DETAIL.
ONE OF THE REASONS THIS IS AN
OBVIOUS TO MOST PEOPLE IS
BECAUSE THE COMPANY ISN'T SMART
ENOUGH NOT TO SCRUB EVERY VIDEO
IT WANTS TO SENSOR.
THE VIDEO DESCRIBES IT AS A
LIMITED STATE.
SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING OUT OF
SCIENTOLOGY.
VIDEOS IN A LIMITED STATE ARE
INTENTIONALLY PUSHED DOWN ON THE
SITE SO THEY'RE HARDER TO FIND.
THEY'RE ALSO DEMONETIZED MANY
PEOPLE WHO POST THEM CAN'T MAKE
MONEY FROM THEM NO MATTER HOW
OFTEN THEY ARE VIEWED.
THINK THAT ISN'T A BIG DEAL?
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF YOU
COULDN'T BUY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ON A
NEWSSTAND.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF ITS
PUBLISHERS WHEN ALLOWED TO MAKE
MONEY FROM SELLING IT?
DOES THAT QUALIFY AS A
CENSORSHIP QUESTION MIKE
OBVIOUSLY, OF COURSE IT WOULD.
WHAT IS THE CRITERIA FOR
CENSORING VIDEOS ON YOUTUBE?
ACCORDING TO THE MEMO
"CONTROVERSIAL RELIGIOUS OR
SUPREMACIST CONTENT QUALIFIES.
SODAS HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL --
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
NONE OF IT IS DEFINED AND IT'S
TOTALLY SUBJECTIVE.
YOUTUBE MAKES THE CALL AND DOES
SO WITH MAXIMUM POLITICAL
INTENT.
FOR EXAMPLE, YOUTUBE DECIDED IT
WAS INFLAMMATORY TO QUESTION THE
NOTION THAT ALL COPS ARE RACIST.
IF YOU DON'T THINK THEY ARE,
YOU'RE IN TROUBLE ACCORDING TO
YOUTUBE, SO HIS VIDEO WAS
DEMONETIZED YET VIDEOS THAT
SUGGEST THAT WHITE PEOPLE ARE
INHERENTLY EVIL WILL REMAIN ON
YOUTUBE WITHOUT ANY
RESTRICTIONS.
THAT'S CLEARLY POLITICAL.
THE MEMO MAKES IT VERY CLEAR
WHERE YOUTUBE SENSORS ARE COMING
FROM AND EXPLAIN THAT THE
COMPANY IS COMMITTED TO THE
FREEDOM TO BELONG INCLUDING THE
RESULTING BENEFITS OF DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION.
OKAY, SOUNDS GOOD.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES THAT MEAN?
AGAIN, IT'S ENTIRELY SUBJECTIVE.
AT ONE POINT, THE MEMO DECLARES
THAT ANY DEMEANING LANGUAGE
AGAINST A DETECTIVE GROUP MAY
RESULT IN A VIDEO BEING REMOVED
FROM A SITE.
WHO ARE THESE PROTECTED GROUPS?
ACCORDING TO YOUTUBE, REFUGEES
ARE A PROTECTED GROUP.
LET'S SAY YOU DON'T LIKE THE
FACT THAT REFUGEES ARE BEING
SETTLED IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD FOR
EXAMPLE.
YOU ASSUME IT WAS YOUR RIGHT AS
A CITIZEN TO DISAGREE WITH
GOVERNMENT POLICY.
NOT ACCORDING TO YOUTUBE.
THERE WILL SENSOR YOUR
COMPLAINTS ABOUT WHAT YOUR
GOVERNMENT IS DOING AND CALL YOU
A BIGOT IN THE PROCESS.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT ONE OF
THE TRUSTED FLAGGERS YOUTUBE HAS
CENSORED IS A SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER WHICH IS AN EXTREMIST
GROUP.
IT WAS THE SPLC THAT SLANDERED
THE FAMILY RESEARCH COUNCIL AS A
HATE GROUP AND LABELED THE PULSE
NIGHTCLUB SHOOTING A RIGHT-WING
ATTACK WHICH AS YOU KNOW, IT WAS
NOT.
THE SPLC IS TOTALLY DISCREDITED
AND ANYONE WHO SPENDS 5 MINUTES
READING ABOUT IT COMES TO THAT
CONCLUSION.
YET YOUTUBE TRUSTS THE
SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW CENTER TO
CENSOR YOUR VIDEOS.
THAT TELLS YOU A LOT.
WE CONTACTED YOUTUBE FOR
STATEMENT ON ALL OF THIS AND WE
ASKED IF THE COMPANY HAD REVISED
ITS POLICIES SINCE THE MEMO WAS
WRITTEN LAST YEAR.
THE COMPANY BARELY RESPONDED.
WE RELATE TO A BLOG POST WRITTEN
BY A GOOGLE LAWYER LAST JUNE IN
WHICH HE AVAILED THE COMPANY
WOULD BE MORE AGGRESSIVE IN
CENSORING VIDEOS IT DOESN'T LIKE
CENSORING VIDEOS IT DOESN'T LIK
LIKE.
ALMOST NOBODY AND POWER IS
FIGHTING BACK AGAINST THIS
CENSORSHIP.
HERE YOU HAVE AN AMERICAN
COMPANY INCUBATED IN AMERICA BY
AMERICANS UNDER THE PROTECTION
OF AMERICAN LAW AND COURTS WHICH
IS NOW WORKING TO UNDERMINE THE
MOST SACRED OF AMERICAN RIGHTS
WHICH IS THE FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION.
YET THE CONGRESS WHICH IS RUN BY
REPUBLICANS RIGHT NOW IS DOING
PRECISELY NOTHING ABOUT THIS.
WHEN YOU ASK THEM, THEY MUMBLED
SOMETHING UNINTELLIGIBLE ABOUT
FREE MARKETS AND GET BACK TO THE
TAX CUTS FOR COMPANIES LIKE
YOUTUBE.
MEANWHILE, THE REST OF US WHO
LIVE HERE AND CARE ABOUT FREE
SPEECH ARE LEFT TO FEND FOR
OURSELVES.
THEY SHUT US DOWN WHEN WE DO
SEND.
IT IS TIME TO COMPLAIN WHILE WE
STILL CAN.
YOUTUBE ISN'T THE ONLY
POLITICIZED PART OF GOOGLE.
IN A MEMO, MANAGERS ARE TOLD TO
REWARD PEOPLE FOR FOLLOWING
THEIR WHITE MALE CULTURE OF
AMERICA.
NOBODY THOUGHT IT WAS RACIST
UNTIL NOW.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THIS IS
EVEN REAL.
TELL US WHAT THE MEMO SAYS.
SPEAK OF MEMO BASICALLY SAYS
EDITS INCLUSIVE PERFORMANCE AND
THEY ARE COACHED AND SOMEHOW
FORCED TO EVALUATE PEOPLE ON
MANAGERS ON THE FEEDBACK THEY
GIVE TO THEIR EMPLOYEES.
THIS MEMO IS ABOUT WHEN YOU GIVE
FEEDBACK TO YOUR EMPLOYEES, THE
CAREFUL ABOUT TO POSITIVE
FEEDBACK TO WHITE PEOPLE SUCH AS
MARIST BAY PERFORMANCE AND
INDIVIDUAL EXCELLENCE AND SO
FORTH.
WHEN YOU'RE GIVING FEEDBACK TO
PEOPLE OF COLOR, YOU SHOULD BE
SENSITIVE TO THE FACT THAT THEY
ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE IN FAVOR
OF GROUP ACHIEVEMENT AND
COLLECTIVE VALUES.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO TALK ABOUT
YOU INSTEAD OF TO YOU.
THIS GROSS RACIAL STEREOTYPES ON
BOTH SIDES THAT ARE OFFENSIVE.
THIS IS CLEARLY ABSURD.
JAMES MOORE WAS LET GO BECAUSE
OF GENDER STEREOTYPES, BUT THE
GROUP PERPETUATES RACIAL
STEREOTYPES EVERY DAY.
>> Tucker: THEY DON'T HOLD
THEIR PROGRAMMING STAFF TO THE
SAME STANDARDS.
OF COURSE, THEY DEMAND
EXCELLENCE AT THE BASIS OF THEIR
BUSINESS.
WHAT'S THEIR RESPONSE BEEN?
ARE THEY CONCEDING THIS IS REAL?
>> I DON'T THINK THEY GET IT.
GOOGLE IS TOO POWERFUL TO BE
QUESTIONED.
THEY'VE BEEN GETTING AWAY WITH
THIS.
THEY DESCRIBE ALL CRITICISM OF
THEIR RACE BAITING AND
GERRYMANDERING AS ALL GREAT
CRITICISM.
>> Tucker: WE HAD THE SAME JOB
25 YEARS AGO.
YOU'VE BEEN A CONSERVATIVE ALL
YOUR LIFE.
WHY ARE CONSERVATIVES AND
REPUBLICANS IN WASHINGTON
DEFENDING THIS?
DEFENDING GOOGLE?
WHY ARE THEY DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT IT?
>> I'M AFRAID ONE CRASS REASON
IS GOOGLE SPENDS THE MONEY
AROUND TO BOTH SIDES.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS DO SOME
THING ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE REALLY UBIQUITOUS
EVERYWHERE.
AS A RESULT, PEOPLE KNOW WHICH
SIDE IS THEIR BREAD AND BUTTER.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE RUNNING UP
AGAINST.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PATRIOTS WHO
ARE SHOCKED BY THIS.
THE REASON EXAMPLE JUST THIS
WEEK IS TRYING TO FIELD THE
LAWSUITS.
THEY CALLED IT THE COURT AND
SAID EMPLOYEES ARE BEING
HARASSED.
THE COURT HAS A SEALED IT FOR
TWO MONTHS.
NOT BEEN ABLE TO GO.